اكد قائد قوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان قوات
بلاده تتقدم في مواقع عقرباح دون الاشاره
الى بدء هجوم مضاد وقالت ان القوات البريه
دمرت اللاعبين من المواقع الروسيه في محور
بخموت
بالفعل التطورات مستمره هنا في محاور
مختلفه من الازمه الاوكرانيه اهمها محور
دانيه كالعاده بالفعل هجومات مضاده ليله
امس قالت السلطات العسكريه والمحليه هنا
بانها صدت هذه الهجومات ان كان في المحور
الجنوبي حول مدينه اوغلادار او في محور
مدينه مارينكا او حتى في محور
كوبيانس من الناحيه المتاخمه لمقاطعه خارج
الحديث كما اسلفت عن تحييد مئات الجنود
وعشرات الاليات العمليات الروسيه ايضا
مستمره ووصول القوات الشيشانيه الى مدينه
ماركا وبدؤهم بالاعمال العسكريه هناك حديث
عن معارك ضاريه في مدينه مارنكان واقعه من
الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه من مقاطعه كما
ان مدينه افديفيكا احمد تشهد
اعنف المعارك استخدام لاسلحه متطوره قنابل
ذكيه تستخدمها القوات الروسيه في محاوله
الدخول الى العمق في مدينه
لا تطور لا دخول لاي من القوات الروسيه
الى هذه المدينه وسط صمود اوكراني في
الدفاع عن مدينه ولابد من الاشاره ايضا ان
مدينه افديفكا احمد هي المحور الاهم
القادم ما بعد باخمت وبالحديث عن باقي
ايضا باخمه شاهدت محاولات اوكرانيه من ضمن
نفس الهجوم المضاد تقول القوات الروسيه او
المصادر العسكريه هنا بانها اصدت هذه
الهجومات من الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه لا
بد من الاشاره ايضا ان قوات فاجنر انسحبت
من مدينه باقمت وان الجيش الروسي هو
المتمركز داخل المدينه
والاله العسكريه الثقيله الحديث عن راجمات
المريخ والمدافع تضرب باستمرار كل يعني
الحدود الاداريه للمدينه من اجل الحفاظ
على عدم دخول القوات الاوكرانيه محور هام
ويعني هو جديد لكنه هام مثل المناطق
الداخليه وهو محور
العمق الروسي حيث باتت القوات الاوكرانيه
تدخل باستمرار الى العمق الروسي خلال يوم
امس حوالي 500 قذيفه وصاروخ وصلت الى سقطت
يعني على مدينه ليست هناك ضحايا او اصابات
لكن هناك دمار في البناء التحتيه وما زالت
العمليات العسكريه الاوكرانيه مستمره
بنطاق شامل اي توسيع رقعه المعارك على طول
او امتداد الخط الحدودي ما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وكذلك في المقاطعات التي انفصلت
واصبحت مواليا لمتابعه المزيد
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات